How are you, Cristian Cásseres greets you with
his news outlet, News Now in
Spanish, the city of Las Vegas has
planned a great
fireworks display throughout the entire tourist area
, among the casinos that will launch
fireworks is the
College Resorts World sites area.  and the scratch the highly
anticipated show on set will kick off
at 11pm on sunday and if you're
looking to avoid the crowds at
orchard water park in wilde it will launch
fireworks on sunday at
8.45pm while the
gallery mall and the  grind andy ranch hotels and
the red back hotel will have their
fireworks shows
at 9 p.m. and an hour later
the plaza hotel will also light up the
sky with its show that will begin
at 10 p.m.
and as is tradition the parade
patriotic of samuel in will return
and welcome viewers and although
this year will be a little different a little
less elaborate than other years
or  rganizers assure that the parade
that has 25 floats will offer a
memorable experience for the whole
family
the event is free and our
presenters service suites brain loved
smart cities machines and jaycee fernández
will host the parade this
year
and today is July 2 it is also  the
date southern nevada residents pay
tribute to their favorite phone code
to celebrate the
home football team the lights are
offering a deal on your
tickets to the fire against the
tacoma clicks this saturday price per
ticket  It is 7 dollars and 2 cents and they
are available online, there will also be
a fireworks display at the
end of the game and we leave you with your
forecast for the next 8 days there
on the screen you have the temperatures this
July 4th we will reach 107 degrees
I am Cristian Cáceres  with its prior
informative start in Spanish good
day
[Music]